in this video I want to introduce the
idea of the central dogma which is an
important concept when we think about
molecular biology so the central dogma
essentially is you can go from DNA to
RNA and to protein DNA can first
replicate via a process called DNA
replication and the DNA can then be
converted into RNA via a process called
transcription and RNA can be converted
into protein via a process called
translation so all of these green arrows
here indicate the idea that is the
central dogma that is the central dogma
sort of a crazy big rule now going from
DNA to RNA recall the DNA and RNA are
both nucleic acids they are both nucleic
acids so the process there is called
transcription they're different they're
slightly different but they're both
still nucleic acids so in transcription
what's happening well if you're gonna
transcribe something imagine imagine you
write a letter to your friend right and
another friend of yours wants to copy
that exact same letter right let's say
you wrote your letter in English and
your friend wants to copy your your
exact same letter in English as well so
they do that they copy it right down
there transcribing it and it's been the
same language but even if they write it
in the same language they're writing of
their handwriting might be a little bit
different than yours that's the idea
behind going from DNA to RNA it's the
same language but they're slightly
different transcription is the same
language both of them are using nucleic
acids which are the macromolecules their
monomers are of course nucleotides
specifically deoxynucleotide
ribonucleotides deoxy ribose
nucleotides in the case of DNA and
ribose nucleotides in RNA then going
from RNA to protein that's translation
and the reason why is because
translation involves changing the
language so if you roll a letter in
English and your friend wanted to change
that exact same that letter into Spanish
or some other language that would be
translation so going from RNA to protein
you're changing the macromolecule we're
going from a nucleic acid that's going
to be coding for a protein so the
macromolecules of protein and proteins
are made up of amino acids amino acids
so in that case you're changing the
language that's high remember a
transcription versus translation you'll
notice that I wrote some red arrows here
so what are these red arrows are well so
RNA can actually replicate itself these
are going to be exceptions these red
arrows RNA replication these are
exceptions to the central dogma ok
generally speaking we don't think about
RNA replicating itself but it can
replicate in some viruses some RNA
viruses this can happen in RNA viruses
in addition we can go from its plot it
is possible for RNA to be converted into
DNA so that process is the reverse of
transcription and sure enough it's
called reverse transcription so this is
a example of where you would see reverse
transcription is in retroviruses so
retroviruses are viruses that are RNA
viruses that can that have an enzyme
called reverse transcriptase which
allows them to turn their RNA into DNA
so an example is retrovirus is an
example of a particular retrovirus is
HIV HIV is a human immunodeficiency
virus and it is a retrovirus and it's a
very big problem it's very hard to deal
with or treat but
generally speaking these green arrows
are or represent the central dogma I
hope that video was pretty simple
straightforward and helpful and
understanding what's going on central
blog why one last thing I am a tutor if
you live in Southern California feel
free to contact me via email at move
University at gmail.com to the
description below for more details
thanks for watching